je suis venu vous dire que vous pouvez
changer le monde vous pouvez aussi
changer le monde nous pouvons tous
changer le monde parce que nous
disposons tous de l'énergie à la fois
renouvelable et durable qui permet de
changer le monde
cette énergie c'est le rêve comment nos
rêves peuvent nous permettre de changer
les choses qui nous entourent
plusieurs il ya plusieurs façons de
rêver on peut rêver comme un artiste
faisait de vous montrer jean giono qui
était connu pour être un voyageur
immobile on peut rêver comme un
entrepreneur et qui mieux nous l'a
démontré que richard branson le premier
entrepreneur qui est allé dans l'espace
et on peut rêver au quotidien être un
entreprenant choisir de changer sa vie
en se changeant soit le rêve c'est
l'énergie des énergies
le rêve c'est le carburant de
l'imagination le carburant de la
créativité
j'entends souvent dire on vit une crise
énergétique que nous sommes à l'ère du
pétrole et que bientôt il n'y aura plus
de pétrole
mais est-ce que l'âge de pierre s'est
terminée parce qu'il n'y avait plus de
pierre est-ce que l'âge du bronze c'est
terminé parce qu'il n'y ait plus de
bronze
est-ce que l'âge du charbon s'est
terminée parce qu'il n'y avait plus de
charbon non ces moments s'arrête parce
qu'un homme imagine rêve une nouvelle
énergie et il fait exister se rêve en
fait nous avons tous carburants qui
permettra d'inventer
l'étape d'après nous sommes heureux
d'avoir ce soir une mine de rêve mais
comment l'exploiter bien sûr ce serait
trop facile ça ne suffit pas pour
l'exploiter il va falloir aller chercher
un peu de méthode méthode que je vais
vous proposer de coupe en quatre parties
d'abord ce rêve
cette idée il va falloir être capable de
la décrire de la décrire comme une carte
postale va falloir en faire une visite
notre rêve va devenir une vision et nous
avons la conviction de réaliser cette
vision c'est parti pour réaliser cette
vision faudra l'a transformé en quelque
chose de concret de tangible il faudra
accomplir une mission cette mission nous
donne un cap c'est une boussole
mais ce n'est pas le gps il faut voir
dans les détails nous allons aller il va
falloir définir des mouvements
stratégiques dans la production dans la
communication dans les ventes par la
gestion puis ces mouvements stratégie tu
sens stratégique bas vont eux mêmes être
redécoupés en tâches et il faudra
exécuter ces tâches rédiger un cahier
des charges faire la comptabilité rédigé
un argumentaire de vente toutes les
étapes de l'entreprise compte ça nous
fait voir les choses différemment ça
change nos perspectives et on se rend
compte que pour changer le monde
faut souvent commencé par acheter du
scotch on a toujours besoin de scotch
cet outil est au service de tous les
entrepreneurs
j'entends par l'entrepreneur personnes
qui veulent changer le monde en
apportant quelque chose d'extérieur
mais il est aussi au service de tous les
entrepreneurs non si vous ne voulez pas
créer d'entreprise vous avez bien fait
de venir m'écouter quand même on peut
changer le monde en se changeant soit et
c'est ça être un entrepreneur c'est
avoir conscience de faire le travail
d'un petit point qui lorsqu on changera
de perspectives rappelez-vous ce qu'on a
fait avec le pétrole nous permettra de
voir un plus grand tableau comme le
faisait les pointilliste comme un
tableau de sera chaque point est
important pour dessiner quelque chose de
plus grand maintenant qu'on a vu ce jeu
cette méthode existe ça allait me posais
une question tout à fait légitime
est-ce qu'elle fonctionne ce que je vous
dis je vous le dis pour l'avoir lu pour
l'avoir étudiée pour l'avoir entendu
surtout pour l'avoir vécu enfin pour le
vivre
aussi longtemps que je me souvienne de
mes rêves est toujours rêvé de faire
quelque chose à marseille en provence en
méditerranée j'ai toujours aimé cette
culture cette histoire cette tradition
cette littérature
you know pagnol mistral je voulais faire
partager ce mode de vie et surtout sans
savon
je vous le confesse j'ai rêvé que le
monde entier se laver avec du savon de
marseille
alors j'ai eu ce rêve fallait en faire
une vision vision était le vrai savon de
marseille par la salle de bain de
personnes du monde entier
donc pour réaliser cette vision il me
fallait accomplir une mission
j'avais donc trouvé mon métier j'allais
vendre et produire du vrai savon de
marseille
mais cette mission fait la découper en
mouvement stratégique
le premier le plus important étant de
faire comprendre que nous faisons du
vrai savon de marseille expliquer quel
est le vrai qu'elle est le faut alors
nous est venue l'idée de faire des
ateliers des ateliers où on allait
raconter l'histoire du savon de
marseille faire découvrir ce produit
ces ingrédients et donner le pouvoir à
travers l'information aux gens qu'ils
consommaient le savon de marseille juin
nous avons ouvert première boutique qui
faisait ses ateliers sur le vieux port
puis 2014
nous avons ouvert la première usine ici
on était aussi de le fabriquer début
2015 nous avons ouvert une deuxième
boutique à aix en provence
mais je vous ai dit tout à l'heure le
monde entier de ville de mon département
puisque c'est le monde entier bien sûr
que non il fallait être capable de la
mener à l'étranger et là c'était encore
une fois changé les perspectives tout le
secteur
me voyant arriver avec bienveillance me
disait tu sais tu es jeune tu as tort de
lancer deux factures c'est la chine
c'est les chinois
avec le faux savants de marseille qui
vont conquérir ce marché est là où tout
le monde a vu une menace
il fallait voir une opportunité car s'il
ya un marché pour info savon de
marseille en france il ya un marché pour
un vrai savon de marseille en chine je
suis parti en chine une aventure
fantastique j'ai rencontré des gens
merveilleux et surtout j'ai réussi à
leur faire aimer alors faire adopter mon
savon aujourd'hui nous sommes en chine
nous ouvrons fin 2015 une première
grande boutique à shanghai et attend
beaucoup d'eux de ce marché
j'ai pas encore réalisé ce rêve alors
vous pourrez toujours me dire est ce que
cette méthode marche vraiment ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'elle m'a mené là
où je voulais être y compris ce soir est
la plus belle morale la plus belle
conclusion que je puisse vous donner
c'est rêver rêver pour vous rêvez pour
ce que vous pouvez faire pour les autres
parce que vous ferez quelque chose de
ses rêves
non seulement vous penserez mais vous
dessinerez le monde de demain
merci